All right so to compute this quantity, what we need to do is first take a look at the neighbors of ORD.
In this case, we've got Seattle, Los Angeles, Dallas Forth Worth, not Atlanta but Pittsburgh.
So Kv which is the number of neighbors is 4.
And then we have to count up the number of edges between these neighbor cities.
So in this particular case we've got one edge between Seattle and Los Angeles.
One between Los Angeles and Dallas and that's it.
Pittsburgh doesn't have any edges that connect to any other pink nodes. So that makes this value 2.
Now we need to apply the formula for the clustering coefficient
to see what value we get from this case.
And the formula says it's 2 times the number of links.
Divided by the degree times 1 minus the degree. So in this case we get 1/3.